des disciplines aussi variées que le
golf le tir à la carabine les échecs ou
de badminton des participants
représentants des grandes entreprises
privées des pme ou des entités
institutionnelles et surtout des
sportifs bien décidés à en découdre au
delà de l'esprit compétitif
c'est un peu ça le cocktail gagnant de
ces jeux nationaux du sport d'entreprise
alors il ya ceux qui reviennent comme au
tennis etienne gruner alsaciens venus de
paris il a remporté en 2016
ici même en martinique le tournoi
messieurs avec un autre collègue de
travail et c'est ce qu'il apprécie dans
ce type de compétition l'esprit d'équipé
et puis aussi le plaisir du sport le
plaisir de pratiquer le tennis dans un
dans un
format de compétition mais tout en
restant dans la convivialité et aussi le
le respect des autres le respect de
l'esprit sportif du coup des sportifs de
tous niveaux viennent découvrir la
compétition en natation 80 nageurs ont
fait le déplacement 27 entreprises sont
représentées
il ya certes des licenciés de clubs mais
pas que ici on nage pour et avec les
collègues de travail très très très
bonne ambiance en fait on on voit les
gens entre eux 1 disputé en dehors de la
piscine il s'entend très bien pu arriver
dans l'eau il se battit tout et ils ont
envie de faire une performance c'est
pour ça que bon le sport d'entreprise ça
c'est pas mal c'est à ce niveau là les
gens sa filière et puis ça permet à
certains de remettre le pied à l'étrier
ou plutôt en l'occurrence le bonnet sur
la tête comme pour notre collègue
désormais vétérans mais qui décroche une
médaille d'or dans sa catégorie du 100 m
nage libre
c'est fort agréable parce que un c'est
pour l'entreprise et puis 2 on retrouve
en ce qui concerne la natation d'anciens
nageurs enfin des des personnes avec qui
on est en contact en compétition il ya
10 20 30 ans et on reste effectivement
sur une épreuve extrêmement convivial et
et
même si effectivement le la compétition
reste présente
ailleurs ce sont des batailles
anecdotique auquel on assiste en tout
bien tout honneur bien sûr en
qualifications triplettes de pétanque la
région guadeloupe est opposée à la
collectivité de martinique
le match est serré jusqu'à ce que et
quatre points d'un coup pour la ctm qui
l'emportent
mais au final l'important c'est que ce
jour là sur le boulodrome du lamentin
comme sur les 16 sites retenus pour ces
jeux des équipes qui n'avaient pas
forcément l'habitude de se rencontrer
ont découvert une autre forme de
championnat